now that black panther is out the next
movie that we're going to see an MCU is
Avengers infinity war since infinity war
is the next movie that we'll see I want
to take this video to talk about the
latest character Edition that we'll see
in the film White Wolf before we get
started please be sure to subscribe to
my channel to stay up-to-date on
Avengers infinity war and White Wolf
this character is actually being taken
over by good ol Bucky Barnes which leads
us to believe that the Winter Soldier is
phasing out and the white wolf is being
phased in it's pretty interesting and
creative to see how Marvel's introducing
this character to us because in the
comics the White Wolf is two challahs
adopted brother and obviously since we
know the backstory for the Winter
Soldier
we know that Bucky is not the adopted
brother of T'Challa in the comics the
white Wolf's character name is hunter
and hunter and his parents get in a
plane crash in Wakanda at which his
parents don't survive hunter however
does survive and is found and adopted by
King to Chaka when he gets older King to
Chaka appoints him the leader of a
secret police force the hot tubs are
Ozzy or war dogs which is where he takes
on the mantle of white wolf when tajalli
became King he actually got rid of the
force so white wolf and his war dogs
leave Wakanda and become mercenaries
however having great love for his
adopted brother still the white wolf is
there whenever Prince to chala calls him
this is the traditional comic book story
of white woof since Black Panther just
came out and we've seen Bucky be the
Winter Soldier we know that they are not
sticking to the traditional story which
Marvel has been known to do on the MCU
so how are they going to fuse these two
characters together the white wolf and
the Winter Soldier they have some
similarities but they also have some
differences which I actually think makes
this new White Wolf character more
interesting let's do some side-by-side
comparisons of the white wolf character
and the Winter Soldier the white wolf
doesn't actually have any proprietary
abilities he's just a normal kid whose
plane crashed in Wakanda he was trained
by the wakandan soldiers so he has
skills with hand-to-hand combat and
armed combat as well
sergeant James Buchanan Bucky Barnes
doesn't have any proprietary abilities
himself either he was just a normal guy
who joined the military with his best
friend Steve Rogers after he was assumed
dead Hydra
grabbed him and enhanced his natural
human abilities and gave him a
cybernetic arm but that's about it he's
a master of hand-to-hand combat a master
of armed combat and a master of assault
weaponry as well
much like our friend the white wolf
another thing they have in common is
they are both assassins and mercenaries
this is where the characters kind of
blur together here then you have white
Wolf's love for T'Challa and Wakanda
showing up whenever they need him after
T'Challa took him back to Wakanda and
cured him of the program into Hydra put
into him you can bet that Bucky has a
newfound love for T'Challa and Wakanda
we can see here in the trailers that
when the wakandans are getting ready for
battle Bucky is right in the front ready
to go and fight with them those are some
of the similarities the difference here
is obviously that the Winter Soldier has
a cybernetic arm this I like I think it
gives the character a little something
more I think it adds to the character in
the comics white wolf again doesn't have
any particular ability so most of the
time he's using a gun we can see here in
the trailer Bucky Barnes is now using a
gun and it looks a lot like the gun that
we see in the white wolf comics but now
we're adding the Winter Soldier
cybernetic arm to the equation at the
end of Captain America Civil War Ironman
blows off Bucky's cybernetic arm with a
blast from his arc reactor leaving him
armless in the end credits scene of
black panther when Bucky comes out he is
still armless but in the trailers we see
that Bucky in fact does have a new arm
since he was in Wakanda and sure he was
taking care of him we can absolutely
assume that this new arm is made out of
vibranium in the comics the white Wolf's
character also has the same kind of suit
that Black Panther has it is laced with
vibranium and has the same
nanotechnology allowing it to turn into
camouflage he also has vibranium and his
boots which allow him to fall from
really high distances I would not be
surprised if Bucky gets a similar suit
as he takes on the character at the
White Wolf
Black Panther it was such a success it's
obvious that they are setting white wolf
up to appear in Avengers infinity war
and black panther 2 when it was released
so this is how they'll take the MCU
Winter Soldier and the comic book
version of White Wolf and fuse them
together what do you think of the new
MCU character
White Wolf do you like him or do you
not like him did you prefer the Winter
Soldier are you excited to see this new
character develop on screen let me know
in the comments below and please be sure
to drop a like and please subscribe to
my channel to stay up to date on
Avengers infinity war Marvel and all
things superhero thank you so much for
watching and have a great day
[Music]